[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
بايدن يتوعد بوتين بدفع الثمن والاخير
يؤكد استمرار الحرب ضد العداء الغربي
هلع في تركيا وسوريا بعد اكثر من 6000 هزه
ارتداديه خلال اسبوعين بعد الزلازل
المدمره
السعوديه تودع مليار دولار في البنك
المركزي اليمني والقياده اليمنيه تصفها
بالرؤيه المسؤوله تجاه استقرار اليمن
دائره المنافسه في المحيط الهادئ تتسع
واشنطن تجدد دعم تايوان
تهدد بالتعاون العسكري
[موسيقى]
مع اقتراب حلول الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع
الحرب اشتدت لغه التهديد والوعيد بين
روسيا والمعسكر الغربي الداعم لاوكرانيا
الرئيس الامريكي اختار وارسو المجاوره
لاوكرانيا ليبعث برسائله الى روسيا ويشدد
على دعمه المستمر لكياف في الحرب بايدن
هدد بوتين صراحه بدفع ثمن باهظ جراء
الازمه الحاليه في اوكرانيا بايدن ايضا لم
يضيع الفرصه دون الاشاده بحلف الناتو
ومواقفه الداعمه لاوكرانيا رئيس الامريكي
الذي زارا كييف قبل الحلول بولندا بعث
بتحيه للشعب الاوكراني مشيدا بشجاعته كما
عاد للحديث عن اندلاع الحرب قبل عام واصفا
هذه الخطوه بالقرار الخاطئ
الرئيس بوتين اطلق دباباته لتجوب مناطق
مختلفه من اوكرانيا وكان مخطئا في هذا
القرار الشعب الاوكراني يتحلى بقدر كبير
من الشجاعه الناتو والدول الاوروبيه
اتحدوا في مواقفهم بدعم اوكرانيا واستطاعت
القوات الاوكرانيه ان تحرق الدبابات
الروسيه الناتو ولد من رحم الوحده
بايدن توجه بالكلام مباشره الى بوتين
واصفا اياه بالرجل البعيد عن المنطق كما
اكد عن قرب الاعلان عن حزمه عقوبات جديده
في حق روسيا هذا ولم يفوت الرئيس الامريكي
الفرصه دون الحديث عن حرب الطاقه حيث
اعتبر ان المعسكر الغربي نجح في تجاوز هذه
الازمه التي افتعلها بوتين على حد قوله
الولايات المتحده بحاجه الى بولندا بقدر
حاجه النيتو الى الولايات المتحده لانه لا
توجد طريقه مغايره للعمل في ظل توسع
مسؤولياتنا وحاجاتنا لتعزيز الامن في
اوروبا الامر بهذه البساطه وهذه الاهميه
بل لربما هو اعظم تحالف في التاريخ كله
وليس المعاصر فقط وهنا وجب التاكيد على
دور الولايات المتحده والتزامها الحقيقي
وساجادل بان الناتو اليوم في افضل احواله
وكما قلت للرئيس الاوكراني بالامس في كييف
بانه واجب الدعم اتجاه اوكرانيا
لن يتزعزع
نتابع من وارسو مع موفدنا الى هناك حسين
قنيبر حسين اهلا بك معنا تصريحات قويه من
الرئيس بايدن من وارسون من العاصمه
البولنديه لماذا بولندا ما الذي تريده
بولندا من امريكا وما الذي تريده امريكا
ايضا من بولندا في هذه الحرب الان
لماذا بولندا اولا لان بولندا تشكل حدود
اوكرانيا اولا مع حلف النيتو
وحدودها مع الاتحاد الاوروبي هي قوه قائده
في اوروبا الشرقيه وتعتبر المدخل الرئيسي
لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه والعسكريه الى
اوكرانيا كما ان بولندا استقبلت كما نتذكر
جميعا عندما كنا نغطي قبل عام هنا عند
الحدود الاوكرانيه البولنديه استقبلت
اوكرانيا استقبلت بولندا عفوا ملايين
اللاجئين الاوكرانيين وكانت براي الولايات
المتحده رائده في مجال مساعده هذا البلد
المنكوب بالحرب ماذا تريد بولندا من
الولايات المتحده هي تريد كما قال ماتيوز
مورايسكي رئيس الوزراء البولندي تريد ان
يصبح وجود القوات الامريكيه هنا في بولندا
وجودا دائما وباعداد اكبر تريد ان تنفذ
الولايات المتحده او بان تتحول بولندا الى
مقر دائم لقياده عسكريه امريكيه
اوكرانيا على ما يبدو حسين نعم طيب
بايدن من وارسو اشاد كذلك كثيرا بدور حلف
شمال الاطلسي وغدا هناك اجتماع لبايدن مع
ممثلي دول اوروبا الشرقيه في الحلف ما
المنتظر من الاجتماع حسين
نعم ساجيبك سريعا كنت فقط اقول انك تريده
الولايات المتحده من بولندا هو ان تزيد
بولندا من ميزانيتها الدفاعيه هي اعلنت ان
ميزانيتها الدفاعيه ستزيد بحلول نهايه هذا
العام بواقع لتصبح اربعه في المئه من
اجمالي الناتج الخام لديها كما ان بولندا
ستكرس اكثر من 20% من ميزانياتها الدفاعيه
لشراء اسلحه ومعدات حديثه وهذا ما تطلبه
الولايات المتحده بالنسبه للاجتماع يوم غد
بين الرئيس الامريكي وتسع دول في اوروبا
الشرقيه اعضاء في حلف الناتو الهدف منه
تعزيز التحالف السياسي والامني والعسكري
والاقتصادي بين الولايات المتحده وهذه
الدول هذه الدول هي بلغاريا تشيكياس
لوفاكيا لتوانيا
وايضا رومانيا وهنغاريا وطبعا بولندا هذه
الدول تريد الولايات المتحده منها ان تشكل
راس لها في مواجهه ليس فقط التحدي الروسي
بل التحدي الذي تمثله القوه الصاعده للصين
تقول مصادر دبلوماسيه هنا في وارسو كان
يوما طويلا في القصر الرئاسي في وارسو
الذي يقع خلفي وكان يوما طويلا ايضا في
القلعه الملكيه التي كنا فيها قبل ساعه
والتي القى فيها الرئيس الامريكي خطابه
الذي اعتبر هنا تاريخيا خصوصا عندما قال
ان اوكرانيا لن تكون ابدا نصرا روسيا
وبوتين سيخسر في نهايه المطاف صهيب وغدا
يبدو ايضا سيكون يوم طويل بالنسبه لك في
التغطيه حسين قليبر شكرا جزيلا من وارسو
[موسيقى]
ترقب كبير سبق الخطاب السنوي لرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الموجهه للامه الروسيه
اهميه الخطاب تكمن اساسا في تزامنه مع
اقتراب الذكرى الاولى على اطلاق العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا بوتين الذي
اعلن بنفسه اطلاق هذه العمليه تحدث مره
اخرى عن الحرب المتواصله في اوكرانيا وعن
الصراع المحتدم مع المعسكر الغربي رئيس
الروسي لم يتردد في توجيه سهامه صوب القوى
الغربيه حيث هاجمها بسبب دورها وموقفها من
هذه الحرب
قبل بدء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه قام
الغرب بنقل الاسلحه الى النظام في
اوكرانيا من الدفاع الجوي وغيره من
الاسلحه الثقيله حتى انهم حاولوا ان
يقدموا لهذا النظام اسلحه نوويه وتحدثوا
عن هذا علنا ونشروا قواعدهم بالقرب من
حدودنا والمختبرات البيولوجيه وحضروا
اوكرانيا لحرب كبرى واليوم يعترفون بهذا
علنا ولا يخجلون ويفتخرون بخداعهم وغدرهم
واستخدامهم الاساليب الدبلوماسيه كمسرحيه
فقط
اما فيما يتعلق بالعمليه العسكريه نفسها
والتي لطالما وصفتها بالعمليه الخاصه فقد
جاءت بالاساس دفاعا عن الاراضي الروسيه
يقول بوتين الذي راى ان الغرب يقود حمله
لتدمير بلاده والدعوه الى نبذها كما اعتبر
بوتين ان الغرب يستخدم اوكرانيا واجهه فقط
لمواجهه روسيا وهدفه تحويل الحرب من محليه
الى عالميه مذكرا مره اخرى ان روسيا ليست
في حاله حرب مع شعب اوكرانيا
هناك تغييرات جذريه تحدث في العالم اجمع
واحداث تاريخيه تحدد مستقبل بلدنا وشعبنا
وعلى عاتق كل واحد منا مسؤوليه ولحمايه
بلدنا ومواطنين في اراضينا التاريخيه
وللتخلص من التهديدات التي جاءت من
النازيين الجدد في اوكرانيا منذ العام
2014 تم اتخاذ قرار بدء العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه العام الماضي
مهاجمه المعسكر الغربي استاثرت بالحيز
الاكبر من خطاب بفوت الذي توجه بالكلام
الى الولايات المتحده مباشره منتقدا
واشنطن لضلوعها في الكثير من الحروب حول
العالم على حد قوله بوتين اعتبر ان الغرب
يكيل بمكيالين في دعمه لدول العالم حيث
ينفق الكثير لامداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
بينما لا يقدم الدعم ذاته للدول الفقيره
رئيس الروسي شدد على ان تدفق الاسلحه
الغربيه الى كييف لن يثني موسكو عن مواصله
العمليه العسكريه
الغرب صرف اكثر من 150 مليار دولار لدعم
النظام الاوكراني عسكريا وخصص 60 مليار
دولار للدول الفقيره تيار الاموال الى
الحرب مستمر الغرب يتهم روسيا لنسيان ما
فعله في العقود الماضيه الحروب التي شنها
الغرب تحت شعار الديمقراطيه تسببت في
تشريد مئات الملايين الغرب دعم الانقلاب
الدمويه في اوكرانيا ونشر الكراهيه ضد
روسيا وعليكم ان تعلموا انه كل ما زاد مدى
الاسلحه التي تصل الى اوكرانيا سنكون
مضطرين لابعاد هذا التهديد عن حدودنا خطاب
بوتين تضمن الاعلان عن قرار مهم وهو تعليق
مشاركه روسيا في معاهده ستارت النوويه
الموقعه مع الولايات المتحده وهي الخطوه
التي تطرح تساؤلات حول امكانيه تنفيذ
روسيا لاي هجوم نووي فمعاهده ستارت
الجديده الموقعه سنه 2010 كانت تهدف الى
تخفيض الاسلحه النوويه بين الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد الروسي
ليس فقط في الولايات المتحده بل كذلك في
بريطانيا وفرنسا وجميعها موجهه ضد روسيا
يجب ان نضع ذلك في الاعتبار في الظرف
الراهن لذلك روسيا ستعلق مشاركتها في
معاهده الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه والهجوميه
واذا قامت الولايه المتحده باجراء تجارب
نوويه فنحن سنقوم بالمثل اي حديث عن
الاخلال بنظام الردع النووي غير صحيح
من واشنطن ينضم الينا مايك ملوي نائب
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق مرحبا
بك معنا سيد مايك في اخبار ساعه من
العربيه من بنود معاهده ستارت الجديده
الموقعه بين الرئيسين اوباما ومد فيديف
على تخفيض الحدود القصوى للرؤوس النوويه
الهجوميه للبلدين بنسبه 30% هل تعليق
روسيا لستارت الجديده تؤشر الى انها تستعد
لتجربه اسلحتها النوويه او استخدامها ربما
التي تم ابرامها بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا ترمي لوقف وتخفيض استخدام السلاح
النووي واذ يلتزم كل من الطرفين
بالتخفيض عدد الاسلحه النوويه التي يمكن
نشرها الرئيس بوتين قال بانه سوف يوقف
مشاركته لكنه لم يحدد ما هو الرقم الذي قد
يتم استخدامه لكن هذه المعاهده سوف تصل
الى نهايتها بعد ثلاثه بعد ثلاثه سنه
سنوات وهذا يعني بان روسيا لا توجد لديها
الرغبه بتجدها وهذا يعني بانها قد تبقى قد
تفتح الابواب على سباق تسلح النووي بين
القوى العظمى التي تمتلك الاسلحه النوويه
في العالم هذا امر مثير للقلق لا اعتقد ان
من خلال هذه الخطوه الروسيه سوف تقوم
باستخدام السلاح النووي لكن من المؤكد بان
هذا يحتوي على تهديد حول
مدى دوافع روسيا حول ما قد تفعله في
اوكرانيا في مواجهه الدعم المقدم من
الولايات المتحده
والدول الاوروبيه الى اوكرانيا نعم لكن
سيد مايك اللفت في حديث الرئيس بوتين انه
ارجع تعليق المشاركه في معاهده ستارت
الجديده او نيو ستارت
الى احتماليه قيام الولايات المتحده وانا
هنا اقتبس احتماليه قيام الولايات المتحده
باجراء بعض التجارب النوويه عما يتحدث
الرئيس بوتين هنا
اعتقد بصوره مصاريه بانه يقوم بالقاء
وتوجيه التهم الى الولايات المتحده جزافا
ولا ارى بان الولايات المتحده قد تكون
ملزمه بموجب هذه المعاهده الا ان تتقيد
بالنصوصها واحيانا قد تكون هناك انشطه يتم
اجراءها من قبل بعض الجهات والتحقق المنحه
لكن فقط الرئيس بوتين بالاضافه الى مجموعه
من الدول الاخرى التي قد تخشى من هذا
الامر لكن جل ما قاله قد يكون من قبيل
الفبركه وان
الاوكرانيين لن يقوموا الا
بتقيد بما يقوله الرئيس اللانسكي الذي
ينحضر من اصول يهوديه ويتذكر ما عاشه من
عاشته القوميه اليهوديه في
معسكرات التاريخ سابقا
لا اعتقد بان الولايات سوف تقوم باجراء اي
تجارب نوويه البته نعم لكن سيد مايك هذه
الحرب في اوكرانيا تقترب من اتمام عامها
الاول وهي تغير العالم واثرت اقتصاديا على
كل سكان الكوكب التحركات الاخيره ان كان
الرئيس بايدن وذهبه الى اوكرانيا وجوده
الان في بولندا والتصريحات والتصريحات
المضاده مع الرئيس بوتين اليوم ما الذي
تجعلنا نستقراه لجهه الى الى اين تذهب هذه
الحرب هل نحن ذاهبون الى حرب عالميه او لا
ربما سيكون هناك خفض لهذه الحرب بعد عامها
الاول
للتوتر لسوء الحظ لكنني ارى ان الجدل بين
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها في النيتو فيما
يتعلق بنوعيه الاسلحه التي سوف ترسل الى
اوكرانيا هذا هو المحك وحتى اللحظه هناك
مناقشات بانه قد تقدم الاوكرانيا ستحتاجه
الى الدفاع عن نفسها والهدف المستقبل بعدم
تقديمها تزويدها بطائرات المقاتله مثل 16
التي او بعض الصواريخ ذات المدى الطويل
التي يمكن اطلاقها على مسافات بعيده
تتجاوز شبه جزيره القرمش هذه القدرات التي
سوف تعطى لاوكرانيا
ومساعدتها على استعاده بعض الاراضي التي
تصل الى اكثر من 50% التي تم انتزاعهم
روسيا والولايات المتحده والنيتو قد
يفكرون في
استراتيجيه تعطي اوكر انيا قدره اكبر
لتحقيق هذا الغرض بشكل سريع لفتني في
كلامك انا قلت ان الغرب مستعد لتقديم كل
شيء لاوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها يعني ماذا
لو تعرضت لهجوم نووي هل سيقدم الغرب كذلك
المشهوره والدعم لاستخدام ايضا الاسلحه
النوويه من قبل اوكرانيا ضد روسيا للدفاع
عن نفسها ايضا
في حاله حدوث
اي استخدام السلاح النووي من قبل روسيا في
اوكرانيا لا اعلم ما الذي قد يحدث من جانب
الولايات المتحده لكن كمحلل العسكري يعتقد
بان الولايات المتحده سوف تقوم باتخاذ
اجراء المباشر وفوري ضد ضد روسيا ضد روسيا
وسوف تقوم باضعاف قدراتها على شان اي حروب
او هجمات اخرى في اوكرانيا ولا اعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده سوف ترد عليها بسلاح
نووي مقابل واعمل معمله ان تمتنع روسيا عن
استخدام او شني اي حرب نوويه وان تفكر
اكثر من مره قبل الاقدام على استخدام
السلاح النووي في اوكرانيا سواء كان ذلك
على من منطلق الاسئله الاستراتيجيه او
التكتيكيه يعتقد انهم سوف يقومون بذلك
ولكن اذا ما حدثت الولايات المتحده سوف
يردون بسرعه
مايك شكرا جزيلا لك على انضمامك الينا في
العربيه هذا المساء مباشره
[موسيقى]
ولا شك مشاهدينا ان الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا لعب دورا كبيرا في تمكينها من
الصمود في ساحه المعركه كميات كبيره من
الاسلحه تدفقت وحزم ماليه ضخمه تم ضخها في
ميزانيه كييف لكن في الوقت نفسه فان
الكثير من المساعدات الماليه لاوكرانيا لم
تصل بعد الخبر كشفت عنه صحيفه الامريكيه
التي اشارت الى ان نصف المساعدات التي
وعدت بها الدول الغربيه لاوكرانيا لم تصل
بعد وقدرت الصحيفه قيمه هذه المساعدات
بنحو 35 مليار دولار الصحيفه نقلت ايضا
تصريحا لتيموفي ميلوفانوف المستشار
الاقتصادي في اداره الرئيس الاوكراني
والذي اكد وجود مشكله في مدفوعات
المساعدات حيث انها
متقلبه ومتاخره وغير مستقره
حزم ماليه كثيره اذا تعهد حلفاء اوكرانيا
بدفعها من بينهم الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي
بدا في البحث عن اصلاحات لتنظيم عمليه
تحويل المساعدات الى كيف واتخذ الاتحاد
الاوروبي اجراءات لضمان استقرار عمليه
الدفع لاوكرانيا كما وعد بمساعده ماليه
منتظمه تصل الى اكثر من 19 مليار دولار
خلال العام الجاري بمعدل ما يقارب 1.6
مليار دولار شهريا ويرجع سبب تضاؤل
التحويلات مساعدات الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
حزم الدعم التي تم الاعلان عنها للتعامل
مع المشكله في الاقتصاديه الداخليه من
ازمات الطاقه والتضخم وغيرها
ان زيارتها لقريتي بوتشا التي شهدت جرائم
حرب الروسيه قالت رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه
ان بلادها تقف مع اوكرانيا وانها ليست
وحدها ما يقاتل في هذه المعركه مشيره الى
ان الاوكران بامكانهم الاعتماد على
ايطاليا وانها ستظل تقدم ذلك حتى حتى
النهايه من اجل الحريه حسب قولها
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه محادثات سريه
بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد زلزلان مدمراني اذا ضرب
تركيا في السادس من فبراير الجاري الامر
الذي ادى الى حدوثه الاف الهزات
الارتداديه وبالتالي تولد مخاوف تسببت
فيها كثره التكهنات والاخبار الكاذبه التي
انتشرت عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي اضافه
الى الزلزلين الجديدين لديدين ضرب جنوب
تركيا ايضا بالعكس
زيتون ارضيه فيها تركيا اكملت تدمير ما
تضرر من مباني في الزلزال الاول قوتها
كانت 6.3 على سلم ريختر سته الاف هزه
ارضيه واكثر خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين ضربت
جنوبيه تركيا وشماليه سوريا منذ اول
زلزالين في السادس من فبراير الحالي
كل الارتدادات التي ضربت تركيا وسوريا
والبلدان القريبه كانت عند الاربع درجات
على سلم ريختار الا ان زلزال امس فقد ست
درجات الامر الذي اثار تساؤلات حول ماهيته
هل هي هزه ارتداديه ام انه زلزال اخر
علميا حسب هيئه المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه
تكون الهزات الارتداديه اقل قوه من
الزلزال الرئيسي وتتناقص تدريجيا الى ان
تنتهي هذا يدل ان المنطقه المنكوبه هي في
ذروه النشاط الزلزالي
الهيئه الامريكيه اكدت ان الزلزال الاول
في غازي عنتاب تسبب في كسر على الفالق
الزلزالي طوله يصل الى 350 كيلومترا
ويتطلب هذا النوع من الكسور الى وقت طويل
لكي يلتئم وبالتالي يجب توقع حدوث هزات
اخرى
الاخبار الكاذبه والتنبؤات غير العلميه
التي انتشرت عبر وسائل التواصل اثارت ضجه
وزادت مخاوف الجمهور لكن هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه نفت بشكل قاطع قدره
التنبؤ بالزلازل الكبيره
انس النماسي العربيه
اتبعوا من عمان مباشره معنا الاستاذ في
الهندسه الانشائيه والزلازل في الجامعه
الاردنيه الدكتور انيس الشطناوي دكتور
انيس اهلا بكم معنا في اخبار الساعه يعني
الباحث الهولندي فرانك هوجربيتس يضرب من
جديد هذه المره بعد الزلزلين بالامس كان
توقع صحيح يعني ليس بشكل دقيق ولكن قال
انه سيكون هناك زلزال بين العشرين والثاني
والعشرين من فبراير وهو ما حصل بشكل مباشر
النسخ خائفه الان خاصه بعد الزلزلين
جديدين بالامس هل علينا ان نصدق هذه
التوقعات
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا لك سيدي يعني
حقيقه مثل ما سمعنا بالاعلام وبكل من كل
الخبراء في العالم مثل ما درسنا وتعلمنا
من كل الابحاث الزلازل لا لن يستطيع
الانسان التوقع الزمن الذي سيحصل به
الزلزال من الممكن احتماليا ان نتوقع
المنطقه بشكل عام ولكن ليس الموقع
بالتحديد وبالتالي توقعات
الاخ من هولندا او غيره هي اعمال عرافين
حقيقه ولا تعني شيء بالنسبه لعلوم الزلازل
والتنبؤ بها
والزلازل اللي قاعده تحدث يوميا هي شيء
طبيعي جدا ومعروف لكل علماء الزلازل
والمهتمين بهندسه الزلازل هي زلازل
تتابعيه اذا بدنا نستخدم الاسم الصحيح عن
الارتداديه هي طبيعيه
نتيجه هذا الباحث الهولندي اثار الجدل
خاصه الان نحن في زمن السوشيال ميديا يعني
وفي ظل الخوف الناس تتداول يعني هذه
التوقعات بالكثير من من الخوف في الحقيقه
وهناك نتحدث على انه ربما يستخدم اساليب
اخرى غير المعروفه في علم الزلازل وانه
يستخدم علم الفلك او يدرس حركه الكواكب
الاخرى
لا اعلم بالتفصيل يعني كيف يقوم بهذه
التنبؤات هل يمكن ان يكون هناك ابحاث
جديده يعني غير علم الزلازل الذي الذي
تعرفونه هو تتخصصون فيه يعني هناك
اشياء اخرى يمكن ان تنبئ حقيقه بوجود هذه
الزلازل ام هذا مره اخرى كما ذكرت انه هي
مجرد صدفه او مجرد يعني اجتهاد عراف دعنا
نقول
هي ليست مجرد صدفه هي شيء معروف يعني لما
بيحدث زلزال بقوه 7.8 على
ويلي
بعد عده ساعات شيء متوقع ان يحدث زلازل
تتابعيه تصل الى سته وسته ونص وستستمر هذه
الزلازل لايام ولشهور وقد تستمر لسنوات
ولكن تتناقص مع الزمن عددها ويتناقص قدره
ولكن دكتور ارجوك تحملني يعني حتى حتى
المده الزمنيه التي تحدث عنها هذه ايضا
يعني متوقعه يعني علميا يعني يستطيع ان
يتكهن انه خلال هذه الفتره يمكن ان يحصل
زلزال سيدي يعني لا يوجد اي علوم تربط بين
الفلك وبين القمر والكواكب وبين الزلازل
على الكره الارضيه لا يوجد اي علوم تثبت
ارتباط ذلك مع الزلازل التي تحدث على
الارض انما يحدث انما يحدث من هؤلاء
العرافون
اللي بيتنباوا بهذه الطريقه انه هو بيتنبا
بشيء حقيقي بشيء ممكن يحصل باحتمال قوي
والان اذا صدفت وحصل هذا الزلزال فهو
يضحك وكانه صدق بهذا التنبه واذا ما حصلت
الناس ما تتذكر وبتنسى ثاني يوم ولا حدا
بينتبه له انه اتنبا فبالتالي انا حقيقه
اطمئن الناس انه هذا هذه الزلازل ظاهره
طبيعيه يوميا اي مراقب او مهتم بموضوع
الزلازل يرى مئات الزلازل التي التي تحدث
حول العالم بقدرات او قوه مختلفه من اربعه
الى خمسه وقد تصل الى سته مئات الزلازل
وبالتالي هل هذا التنبؤ حقيقه علميه
الجواب طبعا لا شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ في
الهندسه الانشائيه والزلازل في الجامعه
الاردنيه دكتور انيس الشطماوي
نشر رئيس لجنه شؤون الخارجيه في مجلس
النواب الامريكي مايكل ماكول تغريده وصف
فيها الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد بمجرم حرب
كما اضاف ان الاسد يعامل الشعب السوري
بوحشيه ويحطم البلاد بدعم من روسيا وايران
واعتبر ذاته المتحدث ان الاسد يستخدم
الزلزال لدخول المجتمع الدولي مره اخرى من
خلال الدبلوماسيه رفيعه المستوى مؤكدا ان
العالم لا يمكن ان يقبل بهذا الجزار على
حد قوره
قال وزير الدفاع التركي خروصي اكار لان
اكثر من 20 الف سوريه عادوا الى بلادهم
منذ وقوع الزلزال جنوب تركيا في السادس من
الشهر الجاري وانا فالوزير التركي في
تصريحات عاقبت قيامه بجوله تفقديه في
المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال في مدينه
انطاكيا وجود اي حركه لجوء من سوريا
باتجاه بلاده مؤكدا ان هناك حركه عوده
للسوريين من تركيا الى بلادهم
[موسيقى]
اودعت السعوديه مليار دولار في البنك
المركزي اليمني امتدادنا من حرص المملكه
ودعمها المتواصلي لمسانده الشعب اليمني
تنمويا واقتصاديا وذكر بيان نشرته وكاله
الانباء السعوديه ان هذه الخطوه تؤكد وقوف
المملكه الدائم مع اليمن حكومه وشعبا وانه
من المؤمل ان تسهم في تعزيز القدرات بمجال
تنفيذ برامج الاصلاح الاقتصاديه وجهود
بناء احتياطات لدى البنك المركزي اليمني
لتمكينه من تعزيز الاستقرار الاقتصادي
رئيس مجلس القياده اليمنيه رشاد العليمي
عبر عن شكره للسعوديه بعد ايداعها مليار
دولار في حساب البنك المركزي اليمني وقال
ان السعوديه صاحبه رؤيه المسؤوله تجاه
اليمن ولا طالما ساندت اقتصاد اليمن وخففت
من معاناه شعبه
معنى من القاهره على الصراري المستشار
السياسي والاعلاميه لرئيس الوزراء اليمني
سيد علي اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه
مليار دولار في البنك المركزي اليمني قيمه
الوديعه السعوديه ما الاثر المتوقع لهذه
الوديعه على العمله اليمنيه على ارتفاع
الاسعار في اليمن اسعار السلع اسعار
الوقود وما الى هنالك
مساء الخير تحيه لك وللمشاهدين الكرام
الواقع ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه تختار
الاوقات الملائمه
لتقديم الدعم
للحكومه وللشعب في اليمن الان هذا الايداع
جاء في وقت في وقت مناسب تماما خاصه ان
الحكومه الشرعيه والشعب اليمني تعرض
لعدوان من قبل الميليشيات الارهابيه
الحوثيه على الضمان اللفظيه وبالتالي منع
تصدير النفط وهذا ترتب عليه خسائر خسائر
كبيره يعني كما قدرها رئيس الوزراء في وقت
سابق بمليار دولار وهذا طبعا له تاثير
كبير تاثير يعني على
التاثير على اقتصادي وتاثير على المعيشه
وتاثير ايضا على اسعار صرف العمله الوطنيه
الان بهذه الوديعه التي السعوديه
دفعت بها
دفعه واحده الى البنك المركزي اليمني
يعتقد انها عززت الاوضاع الماليه
لليمن وهي في الواقع
ستسهم بشكل كبير في تحقيق الاستقرار
النقدي والمعيشي وبالتالي لا تستطيع ان
نقول اننا سنشهد خلال المرحله القادمه
قدرا كبيرا من استقرار اسعار العمله
المحليه بل واستقرار
الاسعار بصوره عامه نعم عوده استقرار
العمله اليمنيه كيف سينعكس على حياه
المواطنين اليمنيين
المشكله المشكله الكبيره التي واجهها
المواطن اليمني هو هذا اولا الاضطراب سعر
العمله
والارتفاع
وارتفاعها وبالتالي هذا ينعكس على اسعار
السلع وبالذات السلع الضروريه خاصه في ظل
محدوديه الدخول لدى المواطن اليمني
بالتاكيد ان هذه الوديعه هي ستساعد بشكل
كبير في تحقيق هذا الاستقرار وفي تثبيت
سعر العمله وتثبيت اسعار السلع وهذا سيخفف
من معاناه المواطنين اليمنيين نعم استاذ
علي متى تتوقعون يمكن ان يلمس اليمنيون
الاثر في هذا التحسن على المستوى
الاقتصادي
اعتقد ان
الاثر سيكون فوري اولا يعني انا لا ادري
اليوم يعني ما عنديش معلومات جديده حول
سعر الصرف لكن اتوقع انه غدا سيشهد سعر
الصرف فعلا انخفاض كبير لصالح الريال
اليمني
وبالتالي بعدها ممكن تاتي مرحله معينه
وتنخفض فيها الاسعار اسعار المواد والسلع
الضروريه انا اعتقد انه هذا امر طبيعي
يعني
دخول هذا المبلغ الى البنك المركزي لابد
ان يحدث اثر واثره سيكون بعضه فوري قريب
والبعض الاخر سياتي في مرحله لاحقه شكرا
جزيلا لكم السيد علي الصراري انتم مستشار
السياسي والاعلامي لرئيس الوزراء اليمني
[موسيقى]
قال نائب الادميرال براد كوبر قائد الوصول
الخامس للبحريه الامريكيه ان زعماء
المنطقه يتفقون على ان ايران هي التهديد
الاول والاكثر خطوره مع تصاعد التوترات
بشان برنامج طهران النووي المتقدم وتزايد
الانشطه الخبيثه لايران في المنطقه على
مدار العامين الماضيين على حد قوله
كانت محاوله الاستيلاء الايرانيه فاضحه
ولم يكن هناك ما يبررها لقد كانت بالتاكيد
غير مهنيه والاهم من ذلك انها كانت
انتهاكا صارخا للقانون الدولي منذ ذلك
الحين اجرينا سته تدريبات على نطاق متفاوت
على المستويين الثنائي والمتعدد الاطراف
المنظور السائد بين زعماء المنطقه بان
التهديد رقم واحد او التهديد الاكثر خطوره
ياتي من ايران سمح لنا بالعمل عن كتب مع
اسرائيل
قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان لينا ان
حكم ايران بالاعدام على الايراني الالماني
جمشيد شرمهاد غير مقبول على الاطلاق واكدت
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان التطبيق
ايران حكم الاعدام على شارمهد سيقابل برد
قوي
[موسيقى]
افادت مصادره مطلعه بان كبار مساعدي رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي يجرون محادثات سريه مع
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس منذ شهرين
تقريبا فذلك في محاولات لتهدئه التوترات
المتصاعده في الضفه الغربيه وهذا بحسب ما
اورده موقع اكسيوس
تحركات ومحادثات فلسطينيه اسرائيليه سريه
يجريها كبار مساعدي رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو والرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس في محاوله لتهدئه
التوتر المتصاعد في الضفه الغربيه
بحسب تقرير نشره موقع اكسيوس فان هذه
المحادثات السريه انطلقت منذ شهرين وتعد
من بين اولى الادله على المشاركه المباشره
رفيعه المستوى بين السلطه الفلسطينيه
والحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه الجديده
التي
ركزت على الجهود المبذوله لتهدئه الوضع في
الضفه الغربيه حيث يتصاعد التوتر منذ عده
اشهر وايضا العمل على تسويه التفاهمات
التي ادت الى تعليق التصويت في مجلس الامن
الدولي ضد المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في
الضفه الغربيه والحفاظ ايضا على الاتصال
بين القاده من اجل حل المشاكل على ارض
الواقع وفق موقع اكسيوس الذي اشار الى انه
من غير الواضح اذا كان جميع قاده الاحزاب
في ائتلاف نتنياهو وبعضهم من اقصى اليمين
على علم بالمحادثات ومحتواها الرئيسي
ونقلا عن مستشار الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
كشف موقع اكسيوس بان الفلسطينيين طالبوا
اسرائيل بوقف التوغل في المدن الفلسطينيه
وبان اسرائيل اوضحت انها لا تريد ارسال
الجيش الى مدينتي جنين ونابلس بالضفه
الغربيه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
يقرر الاعتكاف في المنزل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد شدد المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه
على ان الصين عارضت بحزم الاتصالات
العسكريه بين الولايات المتحده وتايوان
مؤكدا على ان الهياكل الذي يتمسك به
المجتمع الدولي لا يهزا او لن يهزها بمبدا
الصين الواحده
لطالما عارضه الصين بحزم الاتصالات
العسكريه بين الولايات المتحده وتايوان
ومبيعات الاسلحه الامريكيه لتايوان لن
يغير استفزاز السلطات الحزب الديمقراطي
التقدمي لاستقلال تايوان حقيقه ان تايوان
جزء من الصين يهز الهيكل الذي يتمسك
المجتمع الدولي بموجبه عالميا بمبدا صين
واحده
هذا واكدت رئيسه تايوان
ان بلادها ستواصل تعزيز العلاقات العسكريه
مع الولايات المتحده للحد من التوسع
الاستبدادي على حد وصفها
تواصل تايوان والولايات المتحده تعزيز
التعاون العسكري وسنتعاون معا بشكل اكبر
مع شركاء الديمقراطيين الاخرين لمواجهه
التحديات العالميه مثل التوسع الاستبداد
وتغير المناخ
قالت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ان الدعم
الصينيه لروسيا بات محدودا وذلكين تريد
البقاء في الاسواق الدوليه وحضرت الخزانه
الامريكيه الصين من محاوله التحايل على
العقوبات المفروضه على روسيا مشيره الى
انها ستتخذ كامل الاجراءات لو حدث ذلك كما
اضافت الخزانه الامريكيه انها تستهدف خطوط
الامداد الروسيه في ذلك المسيرات التي يتم
تصنيعها في ايران
ودائره المنافسه في المحيط الهادئ تتسع
بشكل واضح وتشمل اطرافا متعدده الولايات
المتحده تاتي في مقدمه هذه الاطراف حيث
تسعى بالدرجه الاولى الى مواجهه التهديد
الصيني سيما بعد حادثه المنطاد التي اثارت
جدلا واسعا لكن ليست الصين وحدها خصم
الولايات المتحده داخل المحيط الهادئ بل
كوريا الشماليه ايضا
اثارت حفيظه واشنطن وحلفائها بسبب تجاربها
الصاروخيه المتكرره في المحيط الهادئ
التجديد الصيني ليس وحده الذي يزعج واشنطن
كما ذكرنا بل ايضا الكوريه الشماليه ايضا
وبهذا الخصوص تقدمت الولايات المتحده
باقتراح يطلب ادانه مجلس الامن الدولي
اطلاق كوريا الشماليه للصواريخ الباليستيه
وحتى المقترح على تشجيع على الانخراط في
الدبلوماسيه وحذر من ان عدم استجابه
المجلس لمقترحها ينطوي على مخاطر وتعرض
الصين وروسيا ان يتخذ مجلس الامن مزيدا من
الاجراءات ضد كوريا الشماليه بحجه ان
ممارسه المزيد من الضغط
واستخدمت الدولتان حق النقض الفيتو ضد
مسعا تقودهم الولايات المتحده لفرض مزيد
من العقوبات على كوريا الشماليه في مايو
من العام الماضي
الحقيقه هي ان اولئك الذين يحمون كوريا
الشماليه من عواقب تجاربها الصاروخيه
التصعيديه يعرضون منطقه اسيا والعالم
باسره لخطر الصراع
اصيل من جهتها ظلت متشبثه بموقفها الرافض
لفرض عقوبات على كوريا الشماليه معتبره ان
الخطوه لن تساعد في حل المشكله القائمه
في شبه الجزيره الكوريه والذي لا يتحقق من
خلال فرض
العقوباترا
السعي الحديث لفرض العقوبات لن يؤدي الا
الى طريق مسدود فاص تامل بصدق في
الاستقرار بدلا من الفوضى في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه تدعو الصين جميع الاطراف الى
التحلي بالهدوء وضبط النفس
[موسيقى]
ونعود مره اخرى الى امريكا اقدم رئيس
امريكي على قيد الحياه يقرر الانتقال الى
منزله والاكتفاء بخدمه رعايه المسنين في
المنزل بعد ان قرر تجنب اجراء تدخل طبي
اضافي انه جيمي كارتر الذي فضل قضاء ما
تبقى من عمره مع اسرته ووقف العلاج في
المستشفى
يعاني وهو البلغ من العمر 98 عاما يعاني
من مشكلات صحيه من بينها سرطان الجلد كما
انتشرت الاورام السرطانيه في كبده ومخه
ايضا ولرئيس الامريكي الاسبق محطات بارزه
في حياته السياسيه عندما تراس الولايات
المتحده لفتره واحده بين عامي 77 وواحد
وثمانين
جيمي اقدم رئيس امريكي على قيد الحياه
ولد عام
1924 في ولايه جورجيا
تولى رئاسه امريكا لفتره واحده بين
1977 و 1981
الحدث الاهم على الاطلاق في مشواره كرئيس
توقيع اتفاقيه عام
الاتفاقيه اثمرت عن اعتراف مصر رسميا
باسرائيل
من بين اهم الاحداث الاخرى في فتره ولايته
قطع العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع ايران عام
1979 ردا على اسقاط الشاه
[موسيقى]
واجه عقبات عده خلال ولايته اخطرها احتجاز
اثنتين وخمسين رهينه امريكيه في ايران سنه
حصل على جائزه نوبل للسلام عام 2002
[موسيقى]
في الختام اخبار الساعه لهذه الليله تذكير
بابرز
يتوعد بوتين بدفع الثمن والاخير يؤكد
استمرار الحرب ضد العداء الغربي
هلع في تركيا وسوريا بعد اكثر من سته الاف
هزه ارتداديه خلال اسبوعين بعد الزلزال
المدمر
السعوديه تودع مليار دولار في البنك
المركزي اليماني والقياده اليمنيه تصفها
بالرؤيه المسؤوله تجاه استقرار اليمن
دائره المنافسه في المحيط الهادئ تتسع
واشنطن تجدد دعم تايوان وبكين تندد
بالتعاون العسكري شكرا لكم على كرم
المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]